[Music]
foreign
the future is psychedelic
into the Psychedelic 20s Rick doblin is
the founder of the multi-disciplinary
association for psychedelic studies or
Maps founded in the late 80s Maps has
spent decades working to get FDA
approval for MDMA assisted therapy for
PTSD and related conditions he says that
should happen within the next year this
is about humans helping humans reason
sat down with doplin at the Psychedelic
science 2023 Conference held in Denver
this June where a reported 13 thousand
people gathered to talk about all
aspects of today's psychedelic
Renaissance
[Music]
talk a bit about the beginning of the
Psychedelic Kind of Revolution LSD was
synthesized in the 40s but then it it
kind of made its way into scientific
Endeavor as well as some political ones
in the 50s and 60s what was the main
lesson to take away from the first era
of psychedelics well I think one of the
first things is that when you identify
as a counterculture that you're sort of
sending up a signal that the culture is
going to be scared of it
and so there was that rebelliousness
that Tim Leary had I mean he was kicked
out of West Point so he was the culture
he was well he was kicked out of West
Point just for drinking alcohol though
yes yes before he even learned about
psychedelics and then he sort of
voluntarily left Harvard even though it
was getting more controversial
and so I think the lesson there was that
we need to think about us as moving into
the heart of the system rather than
becoming a counterculture and then the
other part I think was that there was
this parallel that The Advocates often
were exaggerating the benefits of
psychedelics one dose you're spiritually
mystically
educated you're
you know and then was minimizing the
risks and the government on the other
side was exaggerating the risks I was
told that if you take LSD six or seven
times you're certifiably insane and they
were suppressing the benefits so I think
one of the big lessons now is that we
have to really talk about
the risks and the benefits and at the
same time I think there was an over
estimation an overvaluation of the
substance itself that all you had to do
is take this drug LSD or psilocybin and
there wasn't enough focus on the
relationship that the relationship is
what makes it either valuable or harmful
so I think once we've learned those
lessons the other big thing was that
psychedelics in the 60s were very much
identified with anti-war with
anti-vietnam and myself I I thought
Vietnam was a tragedy and and we never
should have done it but now we've sort
of come back
through working with veterans who've
been traumatized so I think the
political symbolism of being
anti-war it became anti-soldier instead
of anti the policy and so now we need
the military to protect our freedoms we
see that with Russia going into Ukraine
and so we're not anti
Soldier even though going into Iraq was
a terrible mistake and what's happened
in Afghanistan is tragic psychedelics
can help heal soldiers who you know are
are following orders and doing good
things or bad or having tough
experiences but the psychedelics which
was a sign of being anti-war is now they
are now kind of being pro-soldier yes
yes and and we're still pro peace in
different ways but but there are times
when you need to defend yourself so I've
come to I think the whole psychedelic
movement has come to see that it's a
dangerous world we live in and that we
do need to protect our freedoms in a lot
of different ways and so we need to
focus on the policies not demonize the
people you um you know the one of the
Cornerstone activities of maps if not
the is working with the FDA to get
approval of MDMA assisted Psychotherapy
talk about how important the substance
is to that therapy why is that therapy
better than regular talk therapy yeah
well to sort of knit these things
together just walking here I heard a
story about one of the Vietnam vet who
was in therapy with MDMA and was still
able to heal but every day up until the
time that he went through MDMA therapy
which was very recently he had Suicidal
Thoughts
so I think what the MDMA does is it
helps reduce
our fear response to emotional threats
to memories that are painful and they
can be overwhelming and we can get stuck
in these patterns of reaction that make
us feel that these experiences and these
memories are overwhelming so every time
they come up we feel that we have to
suppress them and so what MDMA does is
it helps people to feel calmer to feel
more through we could say oxytocin the
self-love self-acceptance that people
can have a diminished sense of fear the
fear is manageable they can control
their reaction to it and then they can
be more calm as they
looking MDMA also enhances memory for
the trauma so a lot of times things that
have been buried that have been so
painful to remember under the influence
of NBA they can come to the surface
because as long as they're buried they
have an unconscious influence and they
create anxiety they create fear they
create hyper vigilance but with MDMA it
makes the therapy more effective but
again what I was saying before is it's
not in the substance that people have
have taken MDMA and if they're
unprepared the difficult emotions come
up and then they end up worse off
destabilized and we've heard many
stories like that so it's the MDMA in
the therapeutic context that really
makes the healing possible you're also a
big supporter and proponent of cognitive
Liberty yes um so for you psychedelics
are not simply about helping people who
have trauma can you talk about that
other dimension of kind of
self-actualization or or yeah really
getting to be the person you want to be
yeah yeah although that's interesting
that this idea of self-actualization
comes from Abraham Maslow in this
hierarchy of needs and
self-actualization becoming your full
realizing your full potential the start
of the human potential movement and
humanistic psychology but what is not
taught in school and what a lot of
people don't know is that in the last
few years of his life Abraham Maslow
changed the hierarchy of needs and above
self-actualization he puts
self-transcendence and what that means
is that you become your full self but
then you realize that yourself is
connected to everything and everyone
even people that are very difficult
different than you and then you start
working to heal the collective and so I
think psychedelics have this possibility
of helping people work through their own
individual traumas and their own
psychodynamics but I think that
everybody is traumatized when we think
about the mass extinctions that's going
on we think about the climate change we
think about the rise of totalitarianism
the decline of democracy in many places
that everybody's got this base level of
fear and anxiety and often people get
overwhelmed by it and then they look for
strong man leaders I think that explains
why a lot of people it's not rational
anymore it's just an emotional tribal
identification and so if we can help the
people that may not necessarily have a
diagnosis but help the everybody and
then also we need to spiritualize people
more we're stuck I think with a lot of
literalisms fundamentalisms ways in
which people
see their nationality or their religion
or as the the one best thing and they
discount others and then they're fearful
of other other cultures and and that's
where we have a lot of the fear of
immigrants even though America is a
country of immigrants
so I think that we need to go beyond the
medicalization and that the legalization
and legal access is absolutely essential
to achieve the kind of mass mental
health and spiritualized Humanity that
we're looking to have that we think we
need for for us to survive and thrive as
a species would you say that that kind
of Baseline of anxiety and polarization
and whatnot is that why we're having a
psychedelic moment now I think there's a
lot of that that there's a lot of the
perceived need I mean with the pandemic
and there's a much more
widespread understanding of the Mental
Health crisis of the crisis of addiction
in America over a hundred thousand
people dying from opiate and Fentanyl
overdoses so I think that's one of the
reasons but I think the other is that we
look at what happened in the 60s and a
lot of the things that came about from
the psychedelics were frightening to the
culture you know there was a lot of talk
about the death rebirth process in the
60s if people had cancer like uh you
know you didn't talk about it you didn't
talk about death women were tranquilized
to give birth and men were not allowed
in the delivery room so birth and death
were kind of separate I think there was
so much death in World War II that there
was this counter-reaction to kind of
push it away I think meditation was seen
with the Beatles bringing Maharishi
mashyogi these weird people in robes and
you know from a different culture that
seemed strange and then even yoga people
were worried if you practice yoga you're
going to become a Hindu or a Buddhist or
whatever so what we realize over the
past 50 years or so the culture has
changed its attitude towards death we
have hospice centers now the first
hospice center in the U.S wasn't until
1974. we have change our approach to
birth we have more birthing centers and
women aren't as tranquilized as much and
men are in the delivery room and
meditation and mindfulness are now
taught at the YMCA it's not going to
take you away and then we also think
about the Psychedelic imagery that
people have during psychedelic
experiences and that's made its way into
art into culture into movies and so I
think we've integrated a lot of the
things that were flash points during the
60s that people were new and scared
about
and in a sense we've integrated
everything except for the psychedelics I
think the other part that's been
happening is the space is going to the
moon and all of the telescopes and all
these things that were we're having a
much more Cosmic perspective and we are
Humanity sits so before it used to be
that Humanity you know Earth was the
center of the universe and everything
was all about us and now we see how
we're just a small part of this
incredible infinity and so I think
people are adjusting and that's
difficult and also through the internet
and other ways that we're all connected
people are bumping up against each other
cultures that were separated and that's
where people are often retreating into
fundamentalism but underneath it there's
awareness that those are not really true
that we need to work in a more
metaphorical way about religion seeing
religions more like languages so I think
it's about this greater understanding of
the Mental Health crisis but it's about
all these things that have happened in
humanity over the last 50 years that has
prepared us for bringing back
psychedelics and hopefully this time if
we're careful and balanced there won't
be the backlash that has happened in the
60s could you give an update on where
Maps is and FDA approval for MDMA
assistant there yeah so we have taken
you know 37 years to get to this point
we have two extremely successful phase
three studies
both in statistical significance and the
magnitude of the effect and in the
safety profile
and we have had a lot of good
discussions with the FDA and so we think
around September of this year we're
going to be submitting What's called the
NDA the new drug application to the FDA
and we think there's a very good chance
that by June of 2024 roughly one year
from now we think that FDA May indeed go
ahead and approve MDMA assisted therapy
as a prescription treatment for PTSD but
it won't be like a normal drug that's
approved it will be approved only under
direct supervision of therapists and
what we're hoping is that we'll be only
under direct supervision of therapists
who have been trained in the method that
we've used in phase three and one of the
big things for me is to try to
help the politicians and The Regulators
understand that a big part of training
therapists is having them have their own
experience with the drugs that they're
going to give to their patients and so I
think we're at this negotiating point
with FDA where they know that the
healings that are happening with
psychedelics are remarkable they've seen
a lot of the data they've also seen that
there haven't been very many advances in
Psychiatry since the ssris in the last
30 or 40 years and they want to find a
way to regulate it I think the other
thing that's happened in the background
has been the legalization of marijuana
and the understanding that medical
marijuana
has a lot of benefits now we I just was
at a meeting with FDA a few days ago in
person about our marijuana project and
the woman in charge of the division of
Psychiatry said that she is very
uncomfortable about the term medical
marijuana because it's not medical until
the FDA says it is but at the same time
they've been making it difficult to do
research but I think that people have
seen this highly demonized drug
marijuana cannabis you know a puff of
party a tragedy that that has now helped
a lot of people and that is sort of I
think there's a diminishing of the the
Zeal for the drug war there's a general
sense and I think that reason magazine
and the Libertarians and others have
made a really good effort over many
decades to help people understand that
the drug war is really a war against
people and it's tremendously
unsuccessful and counterproductive so I
think a lot of the suppression of
psychedelic research has been the
concern that it sends the wrong message
that if these studies show benefits then
it gets in the way of the drug war
ideology so I think the drug war itself
has really lost credibility and is seen
as counterproductive so all those
factors I think make it so that now we
do have the Psychedelic Renaissance what
um what is the difference one way what
you're talking about is kind of the
ultimate Boomer story right where it's
you know the class of 64 or whatever in
the Pacific Palisades you know it starts
you know instead of going to college or
going to war they they turn on tune out
and you know or drop out yeah yeah
Etc
um and now they are the elders and
they're kind of like what we want our
LSD to be legal now we want MDMA we want
um can you talk a little bit about that
Journey uh you know as a generation and
then what are the sticking points with
younger Generations because we have a
generation gap now that's arguably as
big as the one that was in the 60s where
the coin the term generation gap was
coined
um you know what what do psychedelics
mean to Boomers and what do they mean to
Millennials in gen Z yeah well it's hard
for me to speak for anything but the
Boomers but I will say that I don't feel
that generation gap as much I feel it's
like the middle generation that grew up
under the drug war propaganda that
didn't have the internet so that the
younger Generations understand how we're
all connected and how there's just this
Universal you know International
Community and we have to learn how to
work together and there's also an
understanding that these technologies
that we have that that there's a lot of
support a lot of dangers but also a lot
of benefits and so I think the
psychedelics have been not just
restricted to sort of the boomer
generation that's what I was actually
worried about for a long time is would
this just be something that would rise
and fall with the Boomers and when I
ended up I taught a class the only time
I've ever taught a class was at new
College where I went to school in 2001
and that was going to be my question our
younger generation is really interested
in this and they were very interested
because I think they have seen all these
cultural mashups and and they're they're
hungry for deeper connections so I feel
that the the younger people are more
open more willing of
there's been so much of this they've
grown up under not the demonization of
marijuana as much but they've seen the
marijuana legalization and medical
marijuana states
so I think that from a boomer
perspective I think it's just a feeling
of the resistance and the backlash was
so great that it was never clear that we
would see this change in our own
lifetime
and so I think that's where it's just
this sense of kind of Amazement but also
the sense of a crisis I mean the
humanity feels even more of a crisis
point now than it was in the 60s that we
could see then already that we needed to
new move to New forms of renewable
energy that the you know oil industry
was causing you know a lot of problems
and so the solutions have been delayed
Humanity as a whole is kind of waited
till you know hopefully it's not exactly
the last minute but I think there's a
sense of Crisis I mean as an example
just to say my youngest daughter
up until a year or so ago she was saying
that she never wanted to have kids that
she didn't want to bring kids into this
world the world was so stressful and it
was you know so going to hell and all
these you know climate change and
extinctions and so I think she's been a
little bit more hopeful lately but I
think there was just this Mental Health
crisis of this younger generation and
they've looked at what are these
Solutions and I also think that the
Ecstasy and MDMA that came in the 80s
really helped Bridge the generations
that the classic psychedelics are very
challenging they're dissolving your ego
there's challenges of letting go of
being
um open of sort of seeing our identity
as something different and I think the
MDMA is the softener as the way as the
bridge and so MDMA has really been
helpful to sort of ease the fears of the
culture about psychedelics and once
people understand that these different
states of Consciousness can be more
beneficial easier controllable in a
certain way then there's an openness to
the others it's interesting that you
know for psychedelics to kind of go
mainstream both opponents of them and
proponents of them have to kind of
acknowledge they're not as powerful as
we once thought yeah it's not like one
dose miracle cure or one dose you're
enlightened and chromosomal damage or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
there's but there's so much still fear
of and misinformation that has been
promulgated in schools through the Dare
program and others what are the major
political kind of economic or medical
and cultural impediments to the
mainstreaming of psychedelics
well I think the biggest challenge is
going to be the cost because what we say
is that it's not a drug that you take on
a daily basis and that looks like it
doesn't cost that much even though then
you need it for 10 or 20 or 30 years and
then the costs add up but what we're
saying is that this is psychedelic
Psychotherapy psychedelics with therapy
and a lot of therapy so there's going to
be an initial cost that's going to be
larger at the beginning but over time it
will save money so the challenge is
going to be getting insurance coverage
because saying most people will not be
able to afford psychedelic Psychotherapy
in that way that's also why we need to
legalize so that people can do this on
their own with peer support so I think
that's one of the main challenges I
think because the drug war has been more
widely seen as a failure we don't have
that same vested interest from police
also we're understanding and we we do
have a police officers that are
interested in MDM a therapy for trauma
so we're trying to make that point that
this is for police officers is for
prison guards this is for First
Responders so we don't have that now we
did have an interesting a couple years
ago we spoke at the International
Association of chiefs of police
and they have since not led us back but
we had one talk and we just met one
police officer who was also a
psychotherapist sarako Gagarin who then
has gone through our training program
and is now wanting to give MDMA therapy
to other police officers but but we've
been rejected ever since to go back to
the International Association Chiefs of
police so so there are pockets of
resistance I think people have started
to understand that the private prison
system is also a disaster that they have
a vested interest in keeping people in
prison from a business perspective
they're not so much interested in
Rehabilitation I think the challenge is
that people that I talk to worry about
the most are the fundamentalists that
that what we're talking about with
psychedelics is it deepens people's
spirituality but it also moves them a
little bit more from a literal
perspective to a metaphorical
perspective and that also makes them
move away from there's only one right
religion so we see a rise of
fundamentalism in a lot of different
ways but I think they're sort of holding
on to a worldview that's being
challenged in so many different ways and
so we have to demonstrate I think our
challenge is to try to demonstrate the
fundamentalists that if you let go of
the literalism there's a deeper
spirituality and you will not have to
leave your symbols or your religions
that it enriches it rather than
diminishes it and I think the we do not
seem to have resistance from the
pharmaceutical industry so many people
are saying what if you can help cure
anxiety and depression and you do this
deep and you only need a few sessions of
psilocybin or MDMA or ketamine and then
you don't need these daily medications
but the those drugs have gone generic
mostly and they're not big profit
centers for pharmaceutical industry so
we actually don't see resistance from at
least I don't see it from the
pharmaceutical industry I think the
polite petitions the fact that we've
been able to get bipartisan support
through the work with a lot of the
veterans I think one of the biggest
challenges has been the next step which
is for me trying to move into the
Department of Defense to work with
active duty soldiers and so there is the
concern oh you know they want to have a
psychedelic experience and it's all
peace and love and they but I think
that's not going to happen at all and I
think we do see with Russia going into
Ukraine that you know we really need a
strong military to keep us free there's
always these kind of tyrants so I think
the the military is sort of the last
Bastion of cultural acceptance and while
we're working with veterans we want to
work with people that are closer to the
trauma and then the other is adolescence
and what people you know that's been a
big thing about the drug war oh let's
protect the kids and so what people are
often surprised about is that the FDA if
we do succeed in getting permission to
have MDMA assistant therapy as a
prescription medicine
for adults that we're being required by
the FDA to work with traumatized
adolescents and I think that's going to
be really important and what we've seen
with cannabis when it started to be
shown that CBD could help with childhood
epilepsy you start helping people's kids
that's kind of then they're really open
to that and so I think the next steps
for us will be to move into the
Department of Defense move into working
with adolescents and those will be the
final stages of cultural mainstreaming
and acceptance final Yeah final question
you know let's project 40 you know you
Maps has been working at this about 40
years 40 years into the future what what
is your dream I'm so glad you even
picked this 40 years because what we're
talking about is a world of Net Zero
trauma by 2070.
so that is the new animating vision for
me and what that means is that over the
next couple Generations I think things
might get worse we're talking about the
possibility of climate change is not
mitigated very quickly there's some
estimates that there could be a billion
climate refugees by 2050.
and so I think the stresses are going to
be amplifying over time but also I think
if we can mainstream globalize
psychedelics and again not just in a
business model where money can be made
but in a humanitarian approach to where
there's most of the places where there's
massive trauma there's also not hardly
any money and so I think the goal is to
try to heal enough people so that that
we're not adding to the burden of trauma
every year
and when you also traumatize someone
there's multi-generational trauma
people's chromosomes don't change that
quickly their genes don't change that
quickly but the epigenetics what turns
certain genes on and off can be changed
by what happens to you in your lifetime
and then you can also pass that on to
your children and so I think if we can
Envision a world of Net Zero trauma by
2070 and more of a spiritualized
Humanity it'll be more like the island
that Aldous Huxley wrote about but the
way that the book Island ended is the
oil companies come in and crush the
island so what we want to make is the
island is the world and so I think that
this moving into space that we have a
chance at least on one hand of a
spiritualized Humanity in the next 40
years and I do think it'll take multiple
generations to get there
and if we fail at that it's uh very
worrisome because we're like Lemmings
going over a cliff and the other way and
we often wait till the last minute to
make changes and the damages are piling
up but I think over the next 40 years
there's a lot of optimism and a lot of
hope that we would have a spiritualized
humanity and then what would we do you
know we're going to have technologies
that can support us all in terms of our
basic needs so hopefully we'll end up
with a culture that focuses on Art and
Science and music and creativity and
lovemaking and this would be you know
the spiritualized humanity that I
Envision over the next 40 years so
that's great final question what's your
favorite psychedelic
[Laughter]
um
breathing
I would say that because you know Stan
Groff has developed hyperventilation you
know so if you just breathe you can have
psychedelic experiences and what that
indicates that it's in us it's not in in
the pill and but I would say that if I
were stranded on a deserted island and I
could have only one psychedelic
which would be it would be LSD
and I know a lot of people like plant
medicines and stuff but the reason it's
not MDMA even though I do have to be
made more frequently than the classic
psychedelics is that there's a way in
which you can't run away from LSD you
have to surrender to it and we build up
all these ideas and all these defenses
and you know you can maneuver around
stuff with LSD you just got to surrender
to it
so I would say healthy dose of LSD would
be you know if I had only one
psychedelic that would be it but the
MDMA LSD combination is tremendous
MDMA with 5meo DMT is also tremendous so
it's a hard question but that would be
my answer well thank you
[Music]